it's been a wild wet and windy afternoon
here in southern nevada
across the valley strong winds have
ravaged neighborhoods
uprooting trees and causing thousands of
power outages it was insane out there
this morning
thank you so much for joining us at five
o'clock i'm sasha loftis
we are tracking this all with team
coverage tonight sally jeremiah has more
on the path of the storm
madison kimbrough live from a deadly
crash in the southwest valley
but first let's go out to kate houston
who is live in the west valley tonight
with more on how the severe wind is
impacting neighborhoods quite a mess
behind you there kate
yes this storm has caused significant
damages
to homes and businesses all across the
valley i want you to look at what's
going on here
behind me you can see just how strong
these winds are they took out two
massive trees
and caused a trampoline to go flying
into the air
before falling here in this spring
valley neighborhood now as you can see
we do have some tree removal workers out
here
they certainly have their work cut out
for them tonight the homeowner tells me
it sounded like a freight train when the
60 plus mile per hour winds
took the trees down sending twigs pine
cones and debris
all over their street next door two
large trees were completely uprooted
taking out the stairs of their beloved
tree house for a good portion of the
afternoon this road was blocked and
still
is forcing many people to turn around i
did speak to the homeowner who tells me
she's never seen anything like this in
the 30 plus years she's lived here
in the backyard i guess that somebody's
solar came off the roof and it came
flying through the backyard
and landed in another one of my big pine
trees
the landscaper was just screaming run
run and then there was a huge storm
of dust coming towards us i just barely
made it into the house before it hit us
now we are seeing significant damage
from the storm across the valley
this photo sent in to us from a viewer
shows a carport at an apartment
caved in just narrowly missing the car
that's next to it
now the west wind drive-in not spared
from damage either
with gusts taking down one of their
signs or screens
pushing that debris into the sidewalk
now back out here live those strong
winds caused tens of thousands of power
outages all across the valley
and the energy is asking for everyone to
be patient
and to stay away from any sort of downed
wires now we are also going to go live
to sally jaramillo who has been tracking
this storm all afternoon
sally we're still experiencing pretty
high wind gusts out here right now
how long is this supposed to last okay
good question yeah you can see our
camera this is a live look outside of
red rock where we are shaking up with
those strong gusts
we're still seeing that wind advisory in
full effect we want to let you know the
top gusts for today
was north las vegas airport with 72
miles per hour you could see those
strong gusts pushing
all the way up into the 60s right now
we're checking out your radar really
looking around to see if there's any
more shower chances but it really looks
like it's going to taper off
really less than a quarter of an inch of
rain was what kicked in
but we still have that wind advisory not
as strong as what we saw earlier on
but you can expect those gusts to still
peak up into the 45 mile per hour range
for most of your areas all the way into
sunday that 4 a.m hour all the way
also to the lakes very choppy waters all
the way to that six o'clock hour for the
lakes tomorrow current conditions out
there 58 for you
las vegas you can see those north winds
are staying at 17 miles per hour
and this evening we're tracking more
wind down the road it continues for
tomorrow but we do want to also share
with you this video there was so much
video that was shared with us
and definitely it really caught our our
attention our viewers have been sending
in this weather video if you could see
christy pereira thank you so much for
sending this
from the broad acres flea market you can
see all the mess
that all the severe thunderstorm morning
that kicked in around 1 32 p.m really
caused
lots of damage it was a very scary
situation if you want to see
more weather videos make sure you check
out our 8 news now facebook page
also our website 8newsnow.com back to
you sasha